so let's imagine that i'm here now this
is me
at the age actually i'll do this right
now so let's say at the age of 31 and
then i go into the future
so this is a line for the present and
then i go into the future
and this is me again
and this is now at the age of 71. so
i've i've got 40 extra years i've even
picked up a
cane to help me walk around
and finally i go even further in the
future and i'm being very optimistic i'm
going to go ahead and say this is at the
age of 101 i
live to be a centennial and i'm sitting
in a wheelchair and i'm going to
wave
out at you so that's me in a wheelchair
at the age of 101
and
we're going to apply that formula we've
been talking about so much
delta p equals
q times r so i said q
is cardiac output
and we've got r
is resistance so we've got
this formula and let's say i go to the
doctor's office and i go today and i go
in 40 years and i go again when i'm 101
and today they tell me my blood pressure
is
120 over 80 and actually i went not too
long ago and that's pretty much what
they told me it was
and i go in the future
and in 40 years they tell me it's
actually gone up my blood pressure is
now 150 over 90. and in fact i go again
when i'm 101 and they say it's 180 over
let's say 105. so the blood pressure is
rising and that's basically what i'm
told and they say well you know you got
to make sure you eat well and
exercise and that should help your blood
pressure
and i'm left wondering what the
connection is between the two
so
let's figure out what that connection is
exactly so
my blood pressure i just said is 120
over 80 and
if i want to figure out my mean arterial
pressure so my mean arterial
pressure meaning the average pressure in
my arteries i can actually use my blood
pressure to give me a good guess as to
what it's going to be so i know that i
spend about a third my mean arterial
pressure is going to equal a third
times my systolic because i know i spend
about a third of the time
my heart does anyway spends a third of
his time beating and it spends
two-thirds of its time relaxing and the
relaxing
pressure is the diastolic pressure
that's 80. and so that works out to
about 95
and so that's how i came up with that 95
number and that's also why it's not
exactly a hundred which is what you
think an average would be between two
numbers but it's because we don't spend
the exact same amount of time in systole
as diastole
so then if i wanted to figure out here
it would be one-third times 150
plus two-thirds times 90
and that works out to
110
and if i wanted to do it at the age of
101
my mean arterial pressure would be
one-third times 180 plus two-thirds
times 105
and that works out to 100 and
let's see
60 and 70 30.
130.
so i figured out my mean arterial
pressure and then i also let me write
that was a line i also need my mean
venous pressure because we know we're
going to have to
subtract the two from another one
another to get the delta p
delta meaning the difference
so mean venous pressure right now is
about five
and let's assume this is one of a few
assumptions we're going to make let's
assume that it doesn't change and over a
few years
it really stays around the same it's
about 5.
well then if i know that my delta p is
easy to figure out right i can just take
95 minus 5
and that will get me 90. and i can take
110 minus 5 and that's 105
and i can take 130 minus 5 and that's
125.
so i figured out my delta p which is
basically my mean actual pressure minus
my mean venous pressure and that equals
my delta p
okay so far so good
now let me change colors to figure out
my q my flow
and right now i
have let's say a stroke volume i'll
write it up here stroke volume
meaning each time my heart beats about
70 milliliters of blood
go out
so each time my heart beats it sends out
to the rest of the body 70 ml of blood
and that's based on the fact that i'm
about 70 kilos
and my heart rate is about 70 very
relaxed heart rate
and let's assume just as we did with the
mean mean venous pressure that that
doesn't change so this is not going to
change over time
so
this works out to about 5 liters a
minute because
q is simply let me write that here q is
simply
s v times h r
and
so i'm just multiplying those two
numbers together and i get about five
liters a minute and it doesn't change
over time
so five liters a minute here five liters
a minute here
and i should probably mention uh all of
my pressure units should be millimeters
of mercury i didn't write that just to
not clutter up the
board but let's just assume that well
it's not assuming it is millimeters of
mercury so
now using my equation
i can now say well delta p and actually
maybe up here i should even change this
to be blue so that i'm consistent
so delta p equals q times r so if delta
p is 90 and q is five my resistance
equals
uh
18 right i mean it's just a bit of math
that i did very quickly but 18 times 5
is 90.
and here i could figure it out uh
105 divided by 5 would give me a
resistance of 21
and here i would figure out that it's
going to be 25.
so
one thing that i've been told by my
doctors my blood pressure is rising
and two things that i've assumed are
that my mean venous pressure are the
same and that my cardiac output is the
same and if i assume that and that's
definitely not true for everybody but if
i assume that for me
then that means that my resistance has
gone up
over time my resistance has gone up and
let's let's now change screens and
figure out how that could possibly
happen
so let me draw myself out again so i've
got
three versions of me i've got the
present me at the age of 31 i've got the
future me
with a cane at the age of 71
and i've got the really old version of
myself
living at a ripe old age of 101
waving in fact
so
three versions of myself
and if i was to draw out my
arterial tree let's say a simplified
version of my arterial tree let's say
here's a vessel
coming through and i've got let's say
another vessel and this branch is here
and i've got a third vessel and this
branch is here
right now my arterial tree looks pretty
good pretty clean and that's why my
resistance was 18. you know blood is
flowing through very smoothly
it's going out this way to feed the
kidney and maybe my ears and my eyes and
my foot
and it's basically making its way
through no trouble
now at the age of 71 something happens
actually let me just draw a little
divider line at the age of 71 something
happens
i have let's say the same arterial tree
try to draw it the same way
except now i've been eating for 40 years
you know foods that are not the best and
i certainly haven't exercised a whole
heck of a lot i haven't gone to the gym
very often
and now i've got build up of plaque
so let's say i've got a plaque right
there
and i've got a plaque let's say another
one right there
and let's say i have a
plaque right there
so i've got three little plaques and
we'll get into plaque and what what it's
made of exactly in a future video but
for the moment just think of it as
something that's blocking up that vessel
and it's usually made of
fatty substances and macrophages and
cells that are dyed and all sorts of
kind of basically
crud that fills up the vessels
and so because it's filled up the
vessels now here
my radius got smaller
my vessel radius and here it got smaller
and over here it got smaller so blood as
it's flowing through
is having a tougher time getting through
because the radius is smaller in these
spots
and as you know if you calculate total
resistance and that's what actually this
is total resistance
the total resistance
will start to slowly climb up
and in this case maybe it climbs up to
21.
and now years go by let's say 30 more
years go by i'm now in a wheelchair and
i continue continue to not eat so well i
eat you know the same sort of fast food
that isn't healthy for me but i can't
possibly stop because i find it tasty
and at the end of the day my vessels
look like this i have that same one as
before let's say
and let's say this one actually grew
longer so instead of just being part of
the vessel that's it's huge now this one
got very big
and let's say this one up here
actually continued and grew a little bit
as well
but i also picked up another one right
here
let's say and i also got one right here
so i have a few more blocks
in the road and so now my blood is
having a real hard time getting through
because it's got more obstruction
to flow
all my
all my paths
have
a smaller radius and we know and i've
i've mentioned a number of times now
about the relationship between a radius
and resistance and that as
the radius everywhere gets smaller the
resistance is going to get bigger and so
my total resistance here let's say is
about 25.
so now you can see
how
eating certain way and not exercising is
going to lead to potentially developing
these plaques that act as roadblocks and
get in the way of blood flow and the
reason that that's a problem
is that as we see now the radius gets
smaller the resistance goes up
and in the previous slide here we
actually can see now that as a
resistance goes up assuming that the
other things kind of stay the same your
blood pressure can go up
and so when you hear in the doctor's
office that you have a blood pressure of
a certain number over a certain number
that's one thing that we can measure
and what it tells you is a little bit of
information about some of the things
that we can't easily measure
such as resistance so let's stop there
and we'll pick up